my name is Evan that's funny back
stories I've been on vacation in the
last two weeks and while I was on
vacation but doing a good job with being
a vacation or not checking work email
not opening up my laptop there is a jdk
vulnerability issue with some versions
of Java 17 and 18 so my laptop didn't
phone in to corporate network and when I
opened it up last week to build the
slides for this I was quarantined so I
had no internet access so i had to move
my flight up a little bit earlier today
I was kind of into sticks in Southern
Oregon the last two weeks and run to the
Amazon office which is just down the
street plug into the corporate network
run the updates and get on quarantine so
I've been working on these slides for
about hour and 15 minutes demo but I
think it's going to go well so yeah I
work on the elastic Beanstalk team at
AWS I've been with amazon for a little
over three years now and who's used
elastic Beanstalk before who's used
opsworks even fewer how about cloud
formation okay how about just raw ec2
there we go so not what I doesn't the
numbers follow like the expected trends
so elastic Beanstalk is a service that's
been around for about three years and
Beanstalk is all about taking these core
infrastructure services like these two
and you can see and RDS and s3 and cloud
watch and basically leveling up or
distilling all of the API is there's
hundreds of API is between these
services and saying for the applications
that you want to run there's maybe 40
api's that manage that you would want to
manager that you would really care about
so Beanstalk is kind of making an effort
to take all of these core services and
combine them into one cohesive logical
unit that is really focused on you
deploying and managing web applications
so these could be java apps based on
spring HP apps web GUI
api back ends and they sink workers so
we're going to talk about the three sort
of use cases there but that's really
kind of the target market for elastic
beanstalk what we'll talk about today if
you're deploying web apps or AP is
there's a few different environment
types that Beanstalk presents to you or
lets you use the first is this what we
call single instance and I'm going to
just kind of walk through this
architecture diagram and tease out the
individual like core AWS services that
being stocking is exposing to you the
first thing here is an auto scaling
group so an auto scaling group is a
service inside ec2 that's been around
for more than five years and auto
scaling is all about growing and
shrinking capacity but it's even useful
when you have a single instance when you
have one in situ server because if this
ec2 instance dies what should happen you
come back up should be resurrected so we
still use an auto scaling group we set
the min and Max 21 you notice that
there's a DNS name so every elastic
Beanstalk web application gets a DNS
name and bonus points to anyone who can
tell me the the AWS service that manages
DNS route 53 so we use route 53 to
expose the cname for your your
application and it's not routing to an
elastic load balancer in this case so
we're using an elastic IP address an EIP
which is a static IP v4 address and we
slap it on your ec2 instance inside the
auto scaling group we expose monitoring
metrics what's the service that that AWS
uses for monitoring college so cloud
watch exposes metrics for monitoring and
scaling your application logging we will
allow you to pull logs off of an ec2
instance and s3 but there's a new
feature of cloud watch called cloud
lunch logs are going to talk about using
that with dr. in the in the demo in here
in a few minutes and then alerting via
the notification service so when
something happens like an ec2 instance
goes away or your application scales
Beanstalk is just taking all of these
services and binding them into a
cohesive unit for you so single instance
is really great for my wordpress blog
that
only my grandma reads 1 T 1 micro is
totally sufficient for dev and test it's
usually a pretty good choice and then
the next environment type is load
balanced and auto scaling and you can
toggle between these two environment
types and in a load balance and auto
scaled environment you've still got your
your DNS cname it's pointing to an
elastic load balancer in this example
and you choose the scaling parameters
and if you've used auto scaling before
auto scaling has a lot of different
parameters and you can configure it and
fine-tune it via the API or the
management console but we say you're
deploying a web app or an API there's a
few things that you really care about
minimum maximum the number of instances
that are there right now at how you
should add or remove instances based on
load so we're giving you kind of an
opinion on how you would use auto
scaling for a web application and then
the third environment type is what we
call a queue driven worker today so who
is used SQS for simple q service it's a
pull based q that is exposed by a Web
API and the Q based work or notice
there's no elastic IP address or elb
here we are on the hosts in the
Beanstalk environment running an agent
and the agent takes care of efficiently
polling the queue for you so running the
optimum number of threads polling
messages in batch from SQS really
optimized by AWS developers for maximum
throughput from SQS and then we're doing
kind of a neat little trick on the box
and that is just redirecting them or or
posting them to localhost so what this
means is you can write a synchronous
batch process workers in Sinatra or
Django or flask or spring so if you're a
web developer you're probably used to
using these web frameworks so Q driven
worker is about kind of allowing you to
adapt your web dead skills to do these
kind of more asynchronous workloads a
good example here is if you were
collecting information in a form and you
wanted to send an email to that user
that customer via smtp
simple email service you might want
might not want to do that as part of the
request response lifecycle give the smtp
servers down or there's a queue or it's
backed up you might want to queue that
work to happen later so work or tears
are good for those kinds of things that
shouldn't happen as part of a UI request
response by something so those are the
three big environment types that elastic
Beanstalk gives you before docker came
along before it was a twinkle in
anyone's I Beanstalk supported java.net
node PHP Ruby and Python container types
so we took an even more opinionated
stance on you've got a python
application you have some modules or
dependencies that you would Express in a
requirement text you would have the
whiskey interface to the application and
we sort of configured the ec2 instance
to run that way but then docker came
along so we have all these customers who
have been asking for I don't know
glassfish or jetty or Nettie or if you
look at the matrix of possible like
servlet containers or web servers and
languages that people would want to use
it's almost infinite and we don't have
an infinite amount of resources to
custom tailor and custom build these
container types and so dr. is an obvious
like perfect solution for that to allow
customers to define the process exactly
the way they want it and run that
process inside elastic Beanstalk and the
other big win that we see here that I'm
personally a huge fan of is fidelity I
know that all of the container types
like the back of my hand I know exactly
how they work and they're still
sometimes when I do something like
that's not to the convention that
Beanstalk uses and it might work because
I've got our VM set up on my laptop or
virtual end set up some particular way
and it's not exactly the same in
Beanstalk so what I've got working on my
laptop doesn't work when I deploy and I
have to resolve those problems and fix
it with dr. that fidelity is there I'm
using dr. V 1 i'm deploying to dr. v1
deploying a container and it just works
so we're excited about that who's
deployed a doctor container
to being stalked before a couple of
folks I'm going to talk about the three
kind of models that we support for
deploying your applications to docker
the first is the simplest give us a
docker file so when you make an API call
called create application version you
can just send a docker file up and we
deploy that docker file to the ec2
instances and if you have a single
instance environment it goes to one if
you have ten instances in an auto
scaling group it goes to all ten and
what happens when you send a doctor file
to an instance does that just magically
work going to do dr. build and then dr.
run so not the most efficient model
right that first run we're going to do a
doctor pool on all the ec2 instance
instances and then do it build the
subsequent run is going to take
advantage of dr. caching but a really
easy way to get started if you're using
the doctor hub or third-party repository
or running your own then we support a
manifest actually get back to context in
a bit so we've got this manifest file we
call dr. run AWS Jason its adjacent file
or adjacent document and you describe
how we should run a container so you
tell us what the repository and image or
tag name are if you have ports that need
to be mapped and volumes that need to be
mapped so it's basically if you were
doing doctor run on your laptop you're
telling us how to do doctor run on your
behalf in an elastic Beanstalk
environment and then for both the doctor
run manifests and the doctor file you
can of course include the context so you
can push a zip file up that has
everything inside so if you're using add
commands or copy instructions and you
include your zip file there will
actually look at exact you examples of
doing that during the demo so the the
doctor when dot AWS that JSON file a
really simple example of that plugging a
good manifest we've got a version number
here and we're out that when we add or
change the members that we support but
in this sample you know in the hub home
user Evan Dee Brown and I have
an image called a media manager and this
update flag just indicates if we should
do a docker pool every time to see if
exchange so we don't rely on the cached
version exclusively you can change that
defaults and just let the ec2 instances
not phone home and check for an update
ports allow you to define the port that
the image exposes so in this port
mapping I'm saying this image was built
from a docker file that exposes port
8080 and this is important because if
you kind of peel back the surface of the
ec2 instances we're actually running
engine X in a reverse proxy mode on the
host so engine X is receiving HTTP
requests from a load balancer and then
it's using streams or upstream to route
those requests to the docker containers
on the on the ec2 instance so you do
need to tell us that the ports that are
being exposed if you deployed a docker
file and we see an exposed and the
dockerfile will peel that out and make
the assumption based on what we see in
the doctor file so you've got some
flexibility and they're building from
docker file or telling us how to run a
container via this this manifest
convention so the advantage is that the
things that I like about running docker
inside AWS our access to kind of the
ecosystem the other AWS services so I
want to run web apps where one build
api's but it's the ability to connect to
these other things in all of the other
regions around AWS that I think is
pretty powerful some samples and the
bolded examples here we'll look at in a
demo but if you want to run docker
inside of a VPC so a VPC is a some might
call it a software-defined Network it's
a service that allows you to find
subnets and routing tables and security
groups optionally connect that network
back to a non prim network via VPN
gateway have private subnets with you
know non-routable IP addresses you can
do that with elastic Beanstalk DynamoDB
is a no sequel or the key value data
store you can access and use DynamoDB
pretty easily from within doctor will
look at the sample app here in just the
pit who uses RDS postgres my sequel
sequel server and oracle so for sort of
database engines that are fully managed
they run on top of ec2 but we're giving
you a managed relational database and
then kind of just connect to it with
Beanstalk and docker and use it start
writing to it or reading from it cloud
formation is an orchestration service so
it allows you to define the whole
breadth of your application from VPC to
RDS in a template file and then run it
and you can distribute it to your
friends or run it in Tokyo and Sydney
and Virginia supports elastic Beanstalk
and dr. and then cloud watch logs is one
of the the newest services that we
launched this was the summit in New York
I think two or three weeks ago and this
is the ability to access streaming logs
so logs on a host or streamed up to
cloud watch and they're searchable from
within the management console or
accessible from within the management
console and we'll look at a sample of
wiring of power wash logs from a docker
environment here in just a second so I
did promise in the meetup description
that movie light on slides and more
heavy on demos and QA so those are my
slides I'm gonna do the demo now and
then we'll come back to questions and
answers and I'm going to do the demo in
the least formal way possible I'm gonna
disappear sit right here get everyone
hear me in the back so good all right so
um I want to cover to kind of two big
things the first was accessing accessing
a datastore so dynamo dB so if we wanted
to build a doctor appt a doctor based
application of Beanstalk and store some
data inside DynamoDB how could we do
that how can the elastic Beanstalk sort
of facilitate accessing these other AWS
services so I have a sample application
up on github and we've done some videos
on this so I'll give you the link to the
blog and we've got this stuff blog
pretty extensively
this is just a simple flask python app
that is I'm just making you work on this
microphone stuff I'll switch positions
in like three more minutes so this is a
python-based based app we've dr. eyes
dit and this application uses DynamoDB
to store information that's collected
from a form so we need to have our
application basically provision these
dependencies for us and we don't want to
do it manually write like of course I
can go into the management console and I
can click services and I can go find
DynamoDB and do I can click create table
and i can define like the properties of
this no sequel datastore I could write a
really good wiki article on how to do
that and hope that the other devs on my
team follow it but right that's not
repeatable and we want this this process
to be repeatable so elastic Beanstalk
has as much as we have an opinion on how
you would run an application we expose
kind of the underpinnings we expose the
ec2 instances and we expose the ability
to customize everything about the
environment if you want to so it's an
it's an optional thing and this
customization that is really kind of
hidden inside this this dot folder so
it's called daddy be extensions this is
inside our application source and eb
extensions are ya moul formatted
configuration files that allow you to
define like the other things that you
want to use with your Beanstalk
application so i think i've just got
I've got one config file in this
extensions directory I called it setup
config so this is a declarative language
and in this declarative bit we've
defined some resources that we need this
resource is a we've called it startup
signup stable and it's a AWS DynamoDB
table and like everything I was going to
do in the management console and I'm
gonna just level up here a bit yeah
that's better that's like Meerkat Manor
meets live demos it's a new reality if
anyone wants to take that and run with a
new reality show I'll I'll do your first
episode so this is all
stuff we would do in the management
console to create that DynamoDB table we
can define in this file so dynamo has a
schema so you got to have a primary key
and define the type of the primary key
so email is the name of the primary key
it's a string dynamo is unique and
powerful because you tell us how fast
the table needs to be like how much
throughput in terms of reading and
writing that you need I've gone the
super conservative route here and said
this table should have a unit of read
capacity so one week per second and a
unit of right capacity one right per
second this application also needs a
queue and it needs an SNS topic so again
AWS resources that you could create
manually but by declaring them in this
configuration file and bundling it with
our application server when we deploy it
elastic Beanstalk will provision these
things for us automatically the other
like kind of gluing the bits together
here if Beanstalk creates this dynamo
table for us our application needs to
know how to connect to that dynamo table
right it needs to know the name of the
table that gets created and where it
exists so as part of the extensions
model that we've got here we can create
files on a host so after we've created
all of our resources like our dynamo
table and our queue we come in here and
declare that VAR app app config is a
file that should be created these are
the permissions that it should have and
this is the content of the file so this
is just a key equals value configuration
file that's being written to the host
and there's one trick there's sort of a
problem with this and that is this is
actually on the ec2 instance right
because we don't know what's happening
inside your docker container we don't
know if there's a VAR app directory so
this is going to happen on host so we
need to take advantage of volume
mappings or bindings to connect this
configuration file and make it
accessible inside your doctor container
and the place that we do that is back in
our manifest file and I need to switch
off the master branch and go to the
doctor branch we talked about dr. run
AWS Jason
one of the things we care about here is
saying hey there's a there's a host
directory called VAR app and that needs
to be mounted into the docker container
because there's a configuration file
there and so the net effect of this is
that in this git repository we've
defined exactly what the application is
from the the docker file which is here
so here's the here's the process here's
how the process should run and then in
eb extensions here all the dependencies
that the process has so anyone can take
this repository clone it locally deploy
it and you're all going to get exactly
the same thing you can deploy it to the
region in Virginia or Oregon or Northern
California I forget all of the regions
around the world there's like eight and
you're going to get the exact same thing
every single time and what's really cool
is if you decide that you know we're
going to go into production and actually
one read per second and one right per
second is not enough we're probably
going to want to edit this file change
the reek capacity or the right capacity
commit it with a nice message and push
it and hopefully it's going to go into
CI and Jenkins is going to check it out
and test it it's going to get pushed
through our pipeline and promoted and
there's attribution that Evan you know
change the capacity and he did it
programmatically and we can revert those
changes and we're really minimizing as
cool as pointy clicky is in the
management console we're trying to
minimize that and make these things more
declarative and repeatable and version
controllable so that's I'm kind of a
first look at eb extensions pretty much
anything that exists in AWS pretty much
little asterisk there most things you
can declare in these config files bundle
them with your app and have been stocked
provision them on deploy so to deploy
this application we could go to releases
and download a zip file and we could
upload the zip file from within elastic
Beanstalk I'm a big fan of I use git and
especially for these interpreted
languages my development workflow is
very like dependent on get and branching
feature branches and merging those in so
i use EB EB is a command-line tool that
we publish that integrates with get and
pushes it binds you git
Tori to elastic being stalked and runs
it so let's get clone this repository
but down
let's check the network over I was on
the wireless I think less i got
quarantined again faiz on
oh all right let's do this cool trick
just dot cloud there we go
alright so just to get repository if
you've seen the the talk I did it dr.
Khan you can close your eyes for the
next like 30 seconds it's the same thing
it's a local git repo it doesn't know
about elastic Beanstalk so using the eb
tool we need to initialize the directory
making API calls to Bienstock takes
credentials these credentials are in my
local environment so they're showing up
I'm going to deploy to Virginia let's
say Evans demo app is the app name and
this is Evans demo prod is my
environment notice that um let's do this
that's way better web server or q driven
worker this is a web server load
balanced or sure to pick the right yep
got it so we've got all of these
different we call them solution stack so
PHP Python Ruby node number 53 I think
before I went on vacation docker 10 was
number 53 it still is I think it's Alpha
sort so no offense to the doctor folks
this is a load balanced environment we
don't want an RDS database and we're
going to just kind of default through a
few these things so we've told our git
repo or application that it should run
and Beanstalk and how it should run and
now we can EB start I'm not going to
deploy the latest commit but this is
making the API calls now to Beanstalk
and actually starting an environment
with the configuration that we defined
and basically doing a get archived and
uploading that that zip file to be in
stock yeah
you so once it starts we'll do an EB
push and it will push the current branch
that rock thanks for asking so we flip
over to the console now we see this gray
so this is um than the vocabulary that
we use can be a little non-intuitive if
it's the first time you're using
Beanstalk this the higher level
construct is an application so Evans
demo app and an application has an
environment or multiple environments so
an environment is an instance of your
application load balanced or single
instance environment you can have
multiple environments inside an
application construct but it's really
kind of your deployables thing so it's
in it's in grey mode right now so it's
deploying at the doctor logo we can see
the version of docker that's running on
top of Amazon Linux and it's going to
take 10-15 minutes to launch so I'm not
going to sit here in silence I've got an
environment that I launched when I was
eating my bun me earlier and it's ready
to go and this is actually a different
application so we're going to put this
so I pivot over to a slightly different
application and talk about some of the
things we could do with cloud watch logs
and this is a PHP app and the PHP apps
also on github and we talked about it on
the blog that I'll link to here in just
a bit it's also got a branch that's
specific to docker because these
applications existed before we had
doctors support and so we dr. eyes them
and it's kind of nice to compare the
branches and see like what it took to
dr. eyes a PHP or Python App in this PHP
sample application it's a little bits
much more traditional it's a form that
writes to a database rights to mysql and
Beanstalk has the extensions support for
provisioning and RDS database with your
app an RDS database is a little
different like the relational data
stores a little bit different than a no
sequel or key value data store in what
major way like what is different
has a schema someone said it has the ski
mascot a schema so we have to apply the
schema to the to the database at some
point again we don't want to like launch
my sequel workbench and do like the
create tables or create the schema
manually we want that to happen
programmatically so again using eb
extensions and i'm going to actually pop
into textmate here we have a config file
and again so like it's a it's dr. based
but we don't know anything about the
container that you're running so we
can't assume that you have the my sequel
binaries installed on your on your host
so the configuration files allow us to
define packages to install on the ec2
instance so outside of the container
boundary we're using the young package
manager to install MySQL and then we're
running this script it's in the eb
extensions directory and it's called
deploy schema dot and any guesses why
that highlighted line is important yeah
you don't want to run it on Alton in
your load balancing autoscale group it
just needs to happen once like you're
doing rate DB my grade or the jangle
equivalent like schema migration should
ideally happen once from one house so
leader only Beanstalk does leader
election it picks a host and an
important thing to note about that if
you use a leader election is that it's
not necessarily the same leader every
single time so when you go through
deployments an instance could go away
and come back it could scale down and go
away so we can't you no guarantee that
the leaders there every single time so
it's a minor detail but it is important
so we're basically saying on it on one
host run this deploy schema script and
here we're just running my sequel notice
that for an RDS database if you use RDS
with elastic Beanstalk we inject the the
information that you need to know as
environment variables so the hostname
the username the password and the port
are available in the environment
anything that's passed into
a beanstalk environment is also passed
into your doctor container so if you if
you passed an environment variable into
your Beanstalk environment will
propagate it into your container with
the minus e arts and we're just calling
create table and then the last thing
I'll talk about well we can actually
look at this simple application share
your thoughts hope this works hasn't
haven't tested it but then off the
network it worked success there we go so
we've written to already s from our
doctor container if we look at the the
dockerfile again just defining the
process this container this image or the
container was image was built on the
host from the doctor file and we run it
on the ec2 instance for you who's heard
about cloud watch logs so this is like
the last integration piece I want to
talk about cloud watch logs allow you to
run an agent on on an ec2 instance and
push logs so push instead of like
sending them to s3 push them into a
stream in cloud watch logs a stream can
be like a name so VAR log messages could
be a string if you have a bunch of ec2
instances a stream could be an instance
identifier so if you've got 20 ec2
instances you have an ec2 instance ID
that could be an individual screen you
add we aggregate those logs in cloud
watch and you can look at them which is
fun and you can define metrics on them
which is really nice as well so this PHP
sample app what was the what was the web
server i said was running in front of
docker on being City Internet's engine X
is running engine X has some pretty
useful logs requests like gets and posts
to the app static asset requests like
our style sheets and our JavaScript
three weeks ago if I wanted to get those
logs actually it wasn't terrible I can
do well let's do it from the from the
management console I could go to logs
and I can click snap
out logs this has been around for three
years we basically send a message to
each host and we pull the logs into s3
and then you have a log file that you
can look through but you can't really
like this isn't actionable you can't say
I see a lot of 50 threes someone should
get alerted or I'm seeing a lot of 200 s
we should scale out or scale and this is
just like debugging basically cloud
watch logs is debugging but it's tied
into alarming notifications and scaling
metrics so one of the like one of my
favorite new features about Beanstalk is
these extension vials these config files
they can just be yamma files that's fine
but you can also include a zip file
which is a collection of config files
that define some functionality and the
folks on the cloud wife log team said
hey we've we've built a module or a
plugin for elastic Beanstalk that will
just automatically support kalaloch logs
I did a double you get and downloaded
the zip file into my eb extensions
directory and did a push I could open up
the zip file and look at the configs and
how they wrote them but it's several
hundred lines in yambol to like install
the agent and identify the streams and
where the engine X logs are we just
don't care about that so this is the
first example of us sort of publishing a
packaged extension and definitely look
for more of that but it was a double you
get from the documentation into my
extensions directory and i did a push
and what happened was i didn't have to
go to cloud watch and create a cobweb
log stream I didn't have to install the
agent on each ec2 instance which is
totally impractical because if we're
auto scaling and we add a new host it
has to happen automatically and the way
CloudWatch logs really manifest
themselves is in the logs submenu and we
have log groups so I have a log group
for this PHP doctor appt I have one
instance in this environment we'll look
at how we like scale out and scale in
and watch a new new stream show up but
this log stream gives us
just just to prove it I did this at
six-twenty right before Victor came on i
downloaded the zip file and it started
aggregating and pushing them out some
cases it takes about a minute for the
new log entries to show up and cod watch
logs but it's pretty swell to to get raw
access to the slot so we do it for
engine X by default yeah um so it's it's
not in beta format but it's out there
it's only in u.s. East right now they'll
be expanding that and I'm not sure when
searches is scheduled but I'll
definitely add a plus one to the college
team that you've asked for search yeah
it'd be it'd be nice cloud trail logs
not yet not yet but I know I sit next to
the guy who prioritizes features for
being stopped I'll let them know cloud
trail is a service that aggregates API
logs so if you call create instance or
create Beanstalk environment and it's
all about the operations that you
perform on the AWS api's blogging this
so log streams are great i could come in
and define a cloud watch alarm that says
if the two you know HTTP to hundreds are
high or 50 threes or high it's in an
email or scale out or scale in or kind
of whatever you want your regex food
needs to be fairly strong because right
you got to define a regex to pull out
from each line like what matters but the
logs are there there in the console for
you to access if I wanted this scale
this Beanstalk out we expose these
config panels inside the management
console and again like there's a hundred
different AP is for auto scaling and ec2
there's a lot of power there and we've
distilled it down to like six things how
many at a minimum how many at a maximum
you probably don't want to run for ec2
instances in the same availability zone
like an AZ as a physical data center you
want to spread those out so I could say
run this
anywhere or I can be really specific and
say any two or any 344 like maximum
bonus points why would I want to be
selective about the individual AZ that I
choose prices are uniform across zones
but it has something to do with pricing
almost like spot reserved instances if
you if you purchase a reserved instance
which is reserve capacity you purchase
it for a particular zone so if you have
our eyes in u.s. East 1a you want auto
scaling or Beanstalk to run there so you
can pin that down if you like scaling
triggers so we expose a scaling metric
so if your CPU bound or requests bound
or whatever your application
characteristics are you define how to
scale out so add capacity and and in to
remove capacity
oh so I didn't so what did i do here any
three and I chose to buy the UI person a
beer when I get back it cut my bad stuff
so back to the dashboard and we'll see
from our event logs that kind of taking
place I said that Beanstalk takes all of
the services and kind of gives you a
higher level opinionated API on top of
them but it never obscures the core
services so if we go into ec2 we see
that there's our PHP environment that's
the ec2 instance for that environment
and we'll see 3 more instances pop up
here pretty shortly so you know if you
want to terminate it or get the system
logs or change the security group it's
an ec2 instance that you own so that's
that's kind of I think important to know
so all first-class core infrastructure
services but also in the management
console Beanstalk is just managing them
for you you don't pay to use bean stock
itself you pay for the ec2 instances
that it runs obviously or the RDS
databases but the management service
itself is is free so that's probably the
first and last knee based live de moment
adieu and then come home too old for
that kind of questions answers let's do
it
not today number one question that we
get running multiple containers it's one
container per host today but I'm always
curious to hear what your use case is so
what would the second or third or fourth
container be
for sure yeah that's so Damon's like
cron base stuff it's really like a
process of a container that blends every
five minutes microservices something
that we're definitely looking at for
sure
totally
yes
that's a great use case two is like
consolidate them here and then a
deployment pattern that is maybe single
host or maybe like spread out and wired
together less expensive I like that too
yeah one of the things we're going to do
is when giving like I know you can do
this with with eating stuff with folks
but we like to be able to do a rolling
upgrade by spinning out docker
containers on small a small number posts
yep and then start writing to those and
then make sure that you get entry stairs
then as long as I keep switching over so
that requires running early being able
to change live change which for sure
ideally even both yeah that's a great
feature today when you when you deploy a
second application version or a new app
version we actually do dr. run and make
sure that the container launches and
that it's okay and then it's around for
like two seconds and then we do the
engine extra rerouting there and turn it
down and you could imagine how you could
extend that out to like a bee or split
like 90 ten percent traffic routing
actually
correct yeah but there's lots of cool
things that that cannon will be looking
at doing down the road
so if you're doing if you're doing your
database in dr. like preview and
or postgres and doctor and say you're
doing your load balancing or routing an
H a proxy being socks not the not the
right place I would look at officeworks
so op strips is chef based that it has
this concept of different layers the
Beanstalk is really the Beanstalk
concept is a load balancing layer which
is yell be a web application which is
whatever you want and a database tier
which is dynamo RDS but office works is
like you can own any of those layers you
can add layers that haven't even been
invented yet and there's some stuff
happening in the doctor world there
Jonathan because my colleague on the off
switch team did a talk at dr. Khan about
what they're doing for for ops words so
i would i would encourage you to look
the after would be visited yep dockers
for the a player exactly something over
here
I just kind of added to his point it'd
be great if dr. Tanner would launch and
then you would hit that like a home URL
to warm out because our office
unfortunately kind of got the big
exploded so that first request if you
guys like start a container and warm it
up and then swap the ports and export it
that'd be really help for us and kind of
encouragement zero downtime deploys that
are in place ok back ok I know you guys
have rollin too close to your pumps
that'd be great the other thing was I
noticed the use of the elastic Beanstalk
extensions of Yama file and I've also
seen I do a media project example blog
post you guys cool yeah recently the
nested templates Joanna calling me
elastic being socks from the mystic
templates is is there like one you favor
more than other verses writing yamaha or
you know calling confirmation with
nested conflicts um it depends on like
your tolerance for pain like Jason and
Jason so he talked about this blog post
series that we did for the sample
application called a media manager and
I'll just um I'm gonna just pulled out
that post up and kind of characterize
this problem we were trying to solve
with this fairly complicated application
jun 12 so we said um we said that we
have this here's here's what looks
familiar like we have this java
application that we've dr. eyes door
there's a dot there's a java version as
well so you're familiar with like the
little icon that i've used for load
balanced but it's like an enterprise app
which means it has VPC and all these
security controls and it also has a ton
of other like dependencies elastic ash
is a managed memcached or retta's
service it needs to use s3 and it uses
RDS and it uses elastic transcoder and
identity access management so it's a
beanstalk app with lots of dependencies
and it runs inside this this VPC
topology this big network
apology so lots of moving parts there's
a lot of different ways to look at this
some people see their VP sees as things
that exist for a long time the VPC is
defined by the networking team and it
lives for a long time for months or
years other people see this is totally
ephemeral like a VPC even though it's a
complex collection of subnets and routes
and network definitions it should be
creative land destroyable along with the
application that was a similar
challenging approach to take so that's
how we wrote this blog post like the
idea is that the entire stack everything
should be runnable by a developer or an
ops team without having to manually
configure stuff so totally
self-contained and what we did there was
when you're talking about these nested
templates we used cloud formation so I
talked about cloud formation as its
adjacent declarative syntax that is
Jason based that allows you to describe
an elastic Beanstalk application like
what the characteristics are it's docker
based its load balanced it has a minimum
number of instances and Confirmation
also defines in a separate template the
network topology and then confirmation
then a separate template defines the
dependencies are the other resources and
then one template to rule them all is
this master template and it actually
declares these sub stacks and sort of
orchestrates this complex infrastructure
into a version controllable Jason
document it's it was some work to get
that done like it's a fair bit of Jason
to write but I can give you a hyperlink
right now and everyone could just run
this and get the exact same thing and we
can run it in Sydney in tokyo in
Virginia and Dublin so when
repeatability and reproducibility matter
when there are a lot of moving parts or
you see down the road that there will
become more moving parts confirmation is
a is a pattern that I would strongly
encourage encourage you to use
bought a blog post is up i did a video
series on that too so you go through it
and we worked really closely with the
cloud formation teams that all these
service teams to say like this is the
right way to do a large scale this is a
media sharing and conversion service
sharing video files with a beanstalk app
and all of these data support backends
so is blog
yeah the ED extensions could call them
richer million for a you start looks
very much like the confirmation template
button llamo is that it is yeah so I
mean you can write the Commission inputs
and yellow just do parse it into new
Jason you get comments that way too
that's what you learn some of the stuff
it yeah I asked you yeah yeah so um bebê
extensions that we can maybe like
sidebar go into why it looks like
confirmation BB extensions I like amyl
we try to parse the animal first on the
back end it will accept Jason but no xml
right no one's ever asked for that so
expect they will ya is it possible to
change the amazon linux am line crispies
the host of us so the project I'm
working on right now and we're looking
at using core OS okay so if i wanted to
use for wes i know there's an ami
available that could be as talk allow me
to use course so um we have a base am i
that we launched the ec2 instances on
and bootstrap docker into and you can
customize that so in configuration under
instances you could pick ac3 large and
put a custom a my idea so so there's
like two prongs to this yes you can
change the am I it's not going to work
so we we know we have an expectation of
what user land looks like and how we
would bootstrap and what's installed on
amazon linux and where we have we
bootstrap into it and coral s doesn't
fit that that said we get requests for
coral s a boon to and rel as base Oh
support and we're evaluating those so
you can't change it but don't expect
anything good there home from it okay on
that wooden labels
but even though you have expectations I
assumed that if you had an option to
just disable the bootstrapping and
assume that like if we knew a tape that
was to be like
agents running do such a thing right
especially if he's docker
total that yes just being able to
disable yep so unfortunately we thought
long and hard about the bootstrapping
three years ago lefort doctor existed
we're reconsidering it is the
bootstrapping itself is like an API and
there's a contract and like the order
that things happen and then where they
happen and we just right now happen to
own all of that and we're thinking about
how we could almost define the events
that happen in bootstrap and ask you
like what do you want to do here what
docker container do you want to run at
this tier layer we're tossing these
ideas around but nothing hard and fast
right now it's good it's good validation
to hear this from the community
let's go so eight o'clock it's gonna be
weird sitting here for 14 more minutes
and silence yeah yeah notice when we
make the call to deploy a new
application it writes to ssq and then
simply does you see it then up to them
to put application Ross all the nodes is
their way to manually call that so you
deploy our application on one locally so
can't just one know what I like 10 very
savvy so yeah we UCF and up under the
hood to basically do what we call
command service and there's not a way
right that we don't expose the command
service API would so you would want to
like deploy a new version of to ranch
just test to tell you know until you
guys get that kind of gradual rollout
thing working yep yeah the problem there
is its non deterministic so between
calls you wouldn't know like which one
you were getting if we enable that so I
don't think there's there's not a good
story there until we get kind of like
rolling a Persian deployments I wouldn't
i wouldn't even encourage you to try
that yeah kudos for knowing how things
are working at that low level it's cool
well you're all grown ups you could have
left at any point now you can leave in
and won't offend me at all but thanks a
time to dr. to everyone for coming out
and hanging out yeah I'm going to hang
out here for you know if you guys have
questions come up and ask or I'm gonna
go I like my wife and newborn back on
vacation I'm gonna go visit the
king-size bed in the hotel room it's
sleep all night long it's gonna be so
good I'm so excited I had to act like oh
I have to leave I don't want to leave
you but I I knew I'm gonna stop sticks
like 12 hours tonight
go